in this physics here at lindau for the
first time nature paired two laureates
together for each of our five films to
discuss questions vital to science in
the future could the younger scientists
reconcile these Nobel Prize winners
sometimes fierce disagreements if their
Golden Age observational astronomy and
it's a golden age of computer astronomy
I never imagined in my wildest dreams
thirty years ago we'd be able to
simulate the formation of the first
galaxies with moving particles of dark
matter we're able to the first time to
look back to when the first stars
galaxies black holes forms so okay there
are some big questions we still don't
know what dark matter is how should we
go about answering these questions we
thought all these people are doing
studying looking at stars galaxies
looking at all this incremental stuff
should we be focused astronomy should be
told the people that aren't doing good
astronomy and what I think the prices
this is why I disagree that it's a
golden age John Mather was correct when
he said it was the golden age for
observational astronomy I particularly
like twenty years ago they were saying
exactly the same thing it's a very rich
subject still and so it is still a
golden age although I would say maybe
not quite as golden because golden age
is not the absolute level it's the rate
of change and so I think we're in the
exponential growth that's gonna slow
down a little bit but it's still a great
area to be in it's not going to crash I
think
let me float a question now
how long before the fossil energy runs
out anyway you say 100 years so go to a
time beyond that what happened we will
be forced to come up with another
solution and we we always have as an
industry we you mean magic will happen
no research will happen has happened
let me remind you that research does not
make energy energy is conserved research
only makes papers right now it would
have to be nuclear so it depends how
soon like nuclear and some of the the
renewables I mean we do have what
happens when the nuclear runs out solar
energy of course it's more expensive but
not so much more expensive but
civilization has to come to an end or to
fight and so on the economists external
many others they are talking about the
cost of replacing that being one or two
percent of global GDP it's definitely
possible this is nonsense the consensus
among people who make energy who make
our lives is that solar energy is
nonsense that's why they don't invest in
it this is wrong what do you think it
could be looks dark matter I take it
doesn't exist why haven't you asked my
opinion since there was no facts on this
method you can have any opinion you want
I consider that one of those things at
least astrophysicist introduced in an
easy manner have these Saturday
afternoon do I have to believe to this
church of dark metal extreme skeptics I
have to be the true believer even though
use the end the skeptic I think there is
some constraints and some evidence about
the dark matter I think if you look at
the the experimental evidence it's clear
that there is extra gravitational pull
and galaxies I understand in science you
have to have both the things you're
trying and testing and that hold on them
to to fear and realize there could be
alternate
but he is sort of like there's no
evidence for anything you know why do we
need anything new
George moosh thinks that if he comes
there's an explanation of something that
is truth I don't I want to see proof of
it as well do you feel that it's a
problem that something like here at at
lindau every Nobel attendee is male I
think it's very tough for women it's
certainly godly partly if they want to
have two children it means that they in
general there's a break but if you make
it to the point where you're starting a
family if you are still in the field if
you have still gotten to that point in
your career path you've had to jump
several other hurdles on the way there
that is that's one of those like you're
barely making it you just like struggle
and fall over the finish line kind of
hurdles to get over there are so many
others from from middle school to high
school to undergrad to graduate school I
mean I'm not thinking about a family you
know there are many reasons why they
drop out very long concerned when first
of all two daughters my wife is the
demography of Nobel laureates is it was
very atypical of the world as a whole I
will not be surprised that is not so far
distant future people will be asking
where are the white men they aren't in
the lineup of Nobel laureates is here
inflation essentially is for the
layperson what the Big Bang is when the
layperson thinks of the Big Bang
actually with the thing about is this
moment of incredibly fast expansion of
the universe it's expanded unbelievably
fast inflation is not a phase transition
inflation is not it absolutely is its
Norma's amount of heat coming out of
that background so face it's about is an
explosion David you're you're completely
right it's not an explosion because it's
not hotter than a nickel but there is
energy pushing the thing outward coming
from the equation of state of the matter
of the vacuum and Bob this is very
different in general relativity you can
sit on the top of the hill and you're
pushing the universe outward nothing
it's a totally in a sense stationary
there's a killing I know perfectly well
this is a card trick what it's actually
doing is low enough to find out how
these fascinating encounters played out
watch the full films let the record show
that I do not believe this man until I
look it up if I get a little bit